awkward and icy Slovak president Susanna
chaputova invites former prime minister
Robert fitzo to form a government after
Saturday's election even as she is suing
him for calling her a U.S agent
allegations she says resulted in death
threats against her since topping the
polls fito has repeated his promise to
end all military aid to Ukraine if he
can form a coalition he was trying to
get also those voters who for whatever
reason have favorable attitudes towards
Russia
particularly because of past former
Slovak foreign minister Pavel demesh
says fitzo will likely be forced to
compromise on Ukraine when courting
Coalition Partners if you look at
composition of our Parliament which will
comprise of seven political parties
Slovakia is far from being future
Hungary hungary's Victor Orban has not
sent any military aid to Ukraine and
Poland soon to go to the polls too is
threatening to stop over a grain dispute
with Kiev
but in the Ukrainian Capital Monday
fewer signs of European division EU
foreign ministers symbolically meeting
outside EU borders for the very first
time the block proposing billions more
in Aid and a plan to transfer Frozen
Russian assets to Ukraine aiming to to
shore up a United message on Russian
aggression
allow me to repeat it it is an
existential for it it's not just Europe
where cracks are appearing Washington's
short-term budget deal on Saturday did
not include Ukraine funds we're now
working with both sides of the Congress
to make sure that
it does not repeat again the Kremlin
said Monday it expects U.S Aid to
Ukraine to continue but it also expects
fatigue to eventually set in the results
of the next U.S election could determine
whether that's true in Washington and
The Wider West Jeff Redmond Shannon in
London thanks red